radiation has been in the news a lot
lately but the term radiation has just
been thrown around loosely to mean
anything potentially damaging coming
away from a nuclear power plant so what
are people worried about that it's going
to like explode and release radiation
but you don't know what's leaking or
radiation I don't think they actually
know what they're worried about getting
out of the reactor so I want to clear up
this confusion between radiation on the
one hand and the radioactive atoms that
release it on the other the radiation is
the stuff anything that radiates out
from a nucleus we call it nuclear
radiation makes sense and that's the
stuff that can actually do damage to
your molecules and cells I have a source
here which releases beta particles and I
have a Geiger counter which makes it
click every time it gets hit by a bit of
radiation so you can see that there is a
lot of radiation coming from the source
right now it's actually not that much
but you know it sounds like a lot what I
want to point out is that as I move the
Geiger counter away from the source the
radiation very quickly falls off a lot
of this radiation can't really pass
through air what are we worried about
like coming out of the plant
I guess the probably the alpha particles
really we're using the alpha part of us
can't get that far no they can't but so
why are we worried about it I'm just
gonna like diet mainly be the beta
particles that the alpha and beta
radiation can be absorbed by next to
nothing doesn't radiation drop off
proportionately as it goes along like
and it's not a linear relationship but
it's more of an negative exponential
relationship so if the radiation can't
go very far why are we worried about it
well the truth is we're not worried
about the radiation itself
we're worried about the radioactive
atoms that release it so we're worried
about the stuff in here in a nuclear
power plant there's a lot of radioactive
atoms that can escape into the
atmosphere into the environment in the
in case of an explosion and it is those
radioactive atoms that were concerned
about these radioactive atoms
be spread in the atmosphere over
hundreds of kilometers and they can
effectively coat everything with a
blanket of this radioactive dust then
you breathe it in or you eat it and it's
at that point when the radioactive atom
is inside you that it releases its
radiation in a damaging way because then
the radiation is delivered directly to
your cells and it can cause damage to
your molecules and cells which can lead
to two health problems later on so it's
not really radiation that we're worried
about directly seeping out through the
walls of nuclear power plants it's the
radioactive material the radioactive
atoms inside that we're worried about
escaping and then doing damage once
they've reached us